I was talking to you during the
commercial break we started talking
about your husband very talented Benioff
who's co-creator of Game of Thrones and
very talented guy I was just curious if
your husband is the co-creator of that
show how tempted are you to try and get
information from him about what's going
on in the show I would think that would
be my wife doesn't care what happens on
my show she really doesn't you know I
could come home with an arrow through my
head and she'd be like whatever but
clearly people are obsessed with Game of
Thrones you must be trying to find stuff
out
well we aundrea who's Dan's wife and I
we stay we we don't look ahead so we
don't look at dailies and we don't read
scripts so we're basically fans just
like everybody else your talk about the
two so the other co-creator his wife you
just you try you just watch the show
like any civilian yes we watch the shows
like normal civilian so I started seeing
on the internet at the end of last
season these little things about John
snow weather I started hearing you know
is something gonna happen to John snow
and I had had many conversations with
David where I basically said if you do
that I'm literally not gonna be here the
next day like I will pack my bags and
leave because I love John snow and I'm
also with him and you made me be with
him and now you can't take him away
because it's just cheap yeah dumb and
you're saying this to the co-create this
is great who's your husband and you're
telling him don't screw with John snow
right so basically I read somewhere that
he had cut his hair and so I got
terrified because they were still
shooting and so he said don't worry
don't worry I promise don't worry like
cutting your cutting his hair might mean
that he's taking a different role he's
gonna thank you yes and so I said send
me a picture of him where you're with
him where he has the Jon Snow haircut
and then I will rest my case right so he
texted me a picture and two weeks later
he was dead
so he he know he'd fitness and you thank
me out he sent you a fake picture he did
yeah so what happened that's what I'm
dealing with in my marriage yeah well he
know now I know why your kids an [ __ ]
[Applause]
curious about is okay so he comes home
and that episode aired what happened
would you say to your husband he wasn't
here and I I called first I called
Andreea it was like have you seen have
you seen it right and we basically just
staged an intervention with them right
where you said dad you better find a way
to bring him back I don't care what it
takes I don't care how you do it you
just got you got to do it right or else
work your you can be gay with each other
[Laughter]
well might as well been there all this
time because that's what our wives say
to us all the time yeah you know guys
host right now you can be gay together
and you're like sure why not
okay let's do it
you